well we're at a hospital on the eastern
outskirts of kathmandu and this is a
place i think which really illustrates
the multiple challenges
facing the people of nepal as you can
see we're under tarpaulin there is a
fully functioning hospital here
it's not damaged structural engineers
have looked at it but despite that
people are simply unwilling to go inside
because they're so scared that there
might be more aftershocks you can see
more patients
coming in here
they're young they're old we've seen a
huge number of children and i think for
them it is the most difficult i suppose
the positive news from this hospital at
least is that none of the patients are
critical the doctor who we spoke to
earlier on said that they are all stable
they will all recover certainly from
their physical injuries but it's the
traumatic
psychological injuries if you like which
i think will take much much longer for
them to recover from
we've moved outside the hospital grounds
now and many more tents here what
they've done is that they've effectively
moved every ward from the hospital
outside they've labeled the wards up so
we've got ward number one two three all
the way up to ten uh and the beds have
come outside as well and it's
challenging because the monsoon season
is coming there were some pretty large
black clouds earlier on if it rains it's
going to become
that much more miserable
you can see some of the injuries here
many people have got leg injuries this
is simply from falling masonry they're
not
very badly injured but they need
treatment they're getting treatment
local doctors here we've seen uh some
military from the canadian military as
well they've been erecting some of these
tents unicef is here as well so the aid
is getting through but
the challenges are so tricky because
people simply don't want to go inside
because they're so frightened that there
will be another aftershock of course
that one
on tuesday was huge but overnight
tuesday into wednesday there were many
more aftershocks i was speaking to the
doctor earlier and he said that during
one of the big aftershocks there was an
operation going on so while those people
who were
able to move outside the hospital did
one of the patients was under an
anesthetic the doctor carried on
treating him carried on with the
operation despite the ground moving
underneath them and only then did they
move outside a very very difficult
time for the people of nepal